The answer is the first two can be produced.
The third one cannot. And the way to see that
is to follow the rules. So if you start
from sentence, well, we only have one rule from sentence,
so we're always going to end up with subject verb
object. We also only have one rule from subject and
one room, rule from object. So we're always going to end
up with noun verb, followed by object, which also is
replaced with noun. From here, we have lots of
choices, so we can replace the noun with Python.
We can replace the verb with eat, and we
can replace the second noun with cookies. That will
derive the first sentence. We could replace the second
noun with Python, using instead the second choice, that
would derive the second sentence. There is no way
to produce the third one. We can get close.
We can turn the noun into I, following this rule.
We can turn the verb into like, following this rule.
We can't turn the noun into eat. The noun can
either by I, Python or cookies. So that's why we
can't derive the third sentence. The important thing about replacement
grammars is we can describe a large language. In fact,
an infinitely large language with a small set of rules.
This language itself is quite small. But we'll see how to
describe much bigger languages, still using a small number
of rules soon. And it is very precise; we
can figure out exactly what sentences are in the
language, just by following the rules here, doing replacements.